so i wonder how much
things that don't yet exist and can
exist is in the space of algorithms in
the space of recommender systems
so
in the space of how the feed is
generated so we kind of talk about the
actual elements of the
the content that's what we've been
talking the difference between photos
between uh short videos longer videos i
wonder how much disruption is possible
in the way the algorithms work
because a lot of the criticism towards
social media is in the way the
algorithms work currently and it feels
like
first of all talking about
product market fit there's certainly a
hunger for
social media
algorithms that
do something different
i don't think anyone everyone said
complaining this is not doing this is
this is hurting me and this is hurting
society
but i keep doing it because i'm addicted
to it
and they say we want something different
but we don't know what it feels like a
uh
just different
it feels like there's a hunger for that
but that's in the space of algorithms i
wonder if it's possible to disrupt in
that space absolutely
um
i have this thesis that
the worst part about social networks is
that they're
uh
is the people
it's it's it's it's a line that sounds
funny right because like that's why you
call it a social network
um but what does social networks
actually do for you like just think you
know like
imagine you were an alien and you landed
and someone says hey there's this site
it's a social network we're not going to
tell you what it is but it's just what
does it do and you have to explain it to
them just two things one uh is that
people you know and have social ties
with uh distribute updates through
whether it's uh
photos or videos
about their lives so that you don't have
to physically be with them but you can
keep in touch with them that's one
that's like a big part of instagram
that's a big part of snap
it is not part of tick tock at all so
there's another big part which is
there's all this content out in the
world that's entertaining
whether you want to watch it or you want
to read it
and matchmaking between content that
exists in the world
and
uh people that want that content turns
out to be like a really big business
right search and discovery would you
search and discovery but my point is it
could be video it could be text it could
be websites it could be i mean think
back to um
think back to like dig right or stumble
upon or
right
nice yeah but like what did those do
like they basically distributed
interesting content to you right
um
i think the most interesting part or the
future of social networks is going to be
making them less social because i think
people are part of the root cause of the
problem so for instance
often in recommender systems we talk
about two stages there's a candidate
generation step
which is just like of our vast trove of
stuff that you might want to see
what small subset
should we pick for you okay
typically that is grabbed from things
your friends have shared
right
then there's a ranking step which says
okay now given these hundred 200 things
depends on the network right let's like
be really good about ranking them and
generally rank the things up higher that
get the most engagement right so what's
the problem with that
step one is we've limited everything you
could possibly see to things that your
friends have chosen to share
or maybe not friends but influencers
what things do people generally want to
share they want to share things that are
going to get likes that are going to
show up broadly
so they tend to be more emotionally
driven they tend to be more risque or
whatever so why do we have this problem
it's because
we show people things people have
decided to share and those things
self-select to being the things that are
most divisive
so how do you fix that
well
what if you just
imagine for a second that why do you
have to grab things from things your
friends have shared why not just like
grab things
that's really fascinating to me and
that's something i've been thinking a
lot about and just like
you know why is it that when you log on
to twitter
you're just sitting there looking at
things from accounts that you followed
for whatever reason
and tick tock i think has done a
wonderful job here which is like you can
literally be anyone
and if you produce something fascinating
it'll go viral
but like
you don't have to be someone that anyone
knows you don't have to have built up a
giant following you don't have to have
paid for followers
you don't have to try to maintain those
followers you literally just have to
produce something interesting
that is i think the future of social
networking that's the that's the
direction things will head and i think
what you'll find is it's far less about
people manipulating distribution and far
more about what is like is this content
good
and good is obviously a vague definition
that we spend hours on but
different networks i think will decide
different value functions to decide what
is good and what isn't good and i i
think that's a fascinating direction so
that's almost like creating an internet
i mean that's what google did for web
pages
they did the
you know page rank search so discovery
you don't you don't follow anybody on
google when you use a search engine you
just discover web pages and so what tick
tock does
is saying let's start from scratch
let's like
like start a new internet and have
people discover stuff on that new
internet within a particular kind of
pool of people well what's so
fascinating about this is like the
the um field of information retrieval
like i always talked about
and as i was studying this stuff i would
always use the word query and document
so i was like why are they saying
querying documents like they're
literally imagine like
if you just stop thinking about query as
like literally a search query and a
query could be a person i mean a lot of
the way
i'm not gonna claim to know how
instagram or facebook machine learning
works today
but
you know if you want to find a match for
a query the query is actually the
attributes of the person
their age their gender where they're
from
maybe
some kind of summarization of their
interests and and that's a query right
and that matches against documents and
by the way documents don't have to be
text they can be
videos they're however long i don't know
what the limit is on tick tock these
days they keep changing it my point is
just you've got a query which is someone
in search of something that they want to
match and you've got the document and it
doesn't have to be text it could be
anything and how do you match make and
that's one of these like i mean i've
spent a lot of time thinking about this
and i don't claim to have mastered it at
all
but i think it's so fascinating about
where that will go with new social
networks
you